let me ask you a question let's go fast
for the next 10 20 years sure okay
how many more uh presidents or congress
or senate or governor or whatever we're
going to have that's going to come up
with bad policies what is the likelihood
of more shitty policies over the next
two decades 105 yeah yeah i mean both
both parties when they're in power spend
like drunk and sales so this is not a
republican democratic
there is bad policies coming near future
even more
that's why you're seeing the rise of the
middle and the more aoc gets power the
more likelihood is in the next 20 years
a socialist is going to become a
president i i think that the middle is
going to rise i think that virginia
taught the country something about the
silent majority that lives in the middle
of this country no problem but but
walking on eggshells and being afraid to
voice your opinion about what you feel
and you know being concerned about
defending some of trump's policies not
necessarily trump saying that trump
policy was actually good policy you're
so nervous that around around your
friends and peers you end up you know
giving them more of a
argument but this is the point i'm
trying to make i think the midterms are
going to be a biblical
i think obama's record is going to be
broken 63 seats whatever it's going to
be i think americans are up to here with
aoc information here's my point to you
here's my point dude this is why i'm
going with this
i come from a place of
i think bad policies are coming
it's a bipolar relationship meaning one
side of it is winter is coming the other
side of it is future looks bright this
is what's in my brain okay winter is
coming future is bright but here's the
point i'm trying to make to you so what
is that one saying that says you know
save for a rainy day no it's not you got
to prepare for a rainy day okay is this
a rainy day today it's a rainy day today
it's been a rainy season right it's been
a pretty rainy season for the for the
low and middle income not the rich for
the low and middle income it's a rainy
season
okay what did you do the last five ten
years
what what did you do the last five ten
years fifteen years so how about buffett
right now that's sitting on 140 billion
dollars of cash and everybody's calling
him an idiot and he's sitting there for
140. why do you think he's sitting on
cash what do you think he's expecting to
happen you think he's a dummy like you
think he's lost it so the point i'm
trying to make is
fully agree this whole printing stuff
they keep doing i keep making more money
than i'm the richest i've ever been in
my life the more money they print the
more money i make but the principles
values and principles are evergreen
principles
we can't get away from that look coming
into the pandemic
coming into the pandemic
the vast majority of americans who made
75 000 or more
had no savings
no question no rainy day that they're
living like you were living when you
were making thirty six thousand dollars
that's scary to me though it is scary so
so
seventy five thousand dollars of income
and you can't find 20 percent of it to
set aside for debt and savings let me
ask you a question danielle if you were
in charge of banking okay
if you were in charge of banking if
you're in charge of banking let's let's
talk about this i'm actually curious to
know what you say
what would you not do meaning i want to
buy a house i make seventy five thousand
dollars
i make a hundred thousand dollars i make
150 i make 200 pick the number i'm not a
millionaire but i'm making anywhere
between 80 to 250 a year qualify to buy
a house i qualify to buy a house no
matter how much income i make what if
you were in charge of banking what would
you expect my minimum down payment to be
on a house
20 20 what do you think
well
you can qualify for three percent these
days three and a half is fha adam yeah
for once listen to my question okay
if you are in charge not you could
qualify for three percent if you ran
banking what would you want the minimum
to be across the board for whatever
reason twenty percent is the de facto
answer well because exactly twenty
percent typically exemplifies a loan
that's not going to go bad okay
okay and if you do and and it's loan to
value bank today what's the bank doing
today what are they financing a 720 000
loan for today
is it 20 down payment is it 10 percent
is it five percent you are you have a
lot of options
right now in america we have record
levels of home equity that's been built
up which means what which means what is
a down payment if i want to buy a house
today what is the expected down payment
from me expect it to be two 20 and that
and that's low and that i think that's
low i think that's low yes i think
that's low let me explain why that's
slow let me explain why that's slow
listen
when when i bought my first house i did
a story on denver post and this was like
a cover story time i remember that story
yeah why you rent i'm like here's how
much money i make here's how much money
i got here's what and i'm renting and
here's why okay
what are you talking about real estate
people my friends who are realtors what
kind of an article is that you're
hurting our business that's what i
believe in i don't think you should buy
a house if you can only afford to put 10
or 20 down payment i think you should
buy a house if you can put 50 down but
you only put 25. i think this whole idea
of trying to do financing a five ten
percent so what does that do to you
here's what it does
yeah so here's what the conversation
happens with your son with your daughter
you say son
when you get married and you want to buy
a house down payment is 25 percent if
you do xyz i'll come help you out with
12 and a half you come up with the other
12 and a half fine so now there is some
kind of a what involvement versus how it
worked in the 70s
supposed to be why it comes
so for me i think if
if if i'm in charge of banking the whole
this so if you if you think about
families i can only imagine being raised
in your house with you and your husband
i would expect your sons were probably
raised with high standards right
where if you adopted uh
me at 12 years old and i came into your
family and i'm coming from a divorce
family where you know my mom couldn't
control me anymore because i'm like you
know can do whatever the hell i want to
do if i came into your house probably
not going to like it probably going to
be like i can't stand this lady who the
hell do you guys think you are talking
to me like that what do you mean i need
to make my day what do you mean i need
to do this
perfect i think we need to raise the
standards in america very simple
expectations
expectation
so if we do that that 72 000 year person
won't be broke he'll have some savings
agreed yeah but the that's housing the
housing demonstration and he does not
want to hear that shut down they don't
do that realtors do not want to hear
they don't care if you don't want to i
know i don't care if you but they want
someone who can pay the minimum entry
fee three percent get them in yeah and
then when that mortgage defaults hey
sorry we tried to help you out i think
that's right there's two things that are
going on in america and i'm going to
talk really really fast to get this out
the first thing starting in 1990 the
united states increasingly became a
payment-driven lifestyle culture in
other words if you could have the
payment you could have the nicer car
car leases showed up and allowed
consumers to get even nicer cars at
lower how much do you want to pay a
month how much you want to pay a month
so this payment culture came up there
then the you you had 2008 when the real
estate crashed isn't it interesting that
texas required 20 percent there's three
of us that lived in texas remember that
yes it's saved
the fact that texas did not have home
equity that you could pull all this cash
out of your house bingo
it made it not do it in texas no and
guess what happened 2008
i love that that's
that's right it was not the nanny state
saying which you couldn't couldn't do
it's a simple regulation that says we
will not allow houses to be over
leveraged so 20
equity always has to be there in other
words if you put 30 down in your house
and you want to put 10 percent that you
want to get a home equity loan to put
the pool in the bank says oh that's okay
you'll still have 20 equity there you go
there's your pool but california they
let you jack all the way up to five
percent so guess what happened tomorrow
taking out heloc's and all this fun
stuff when you and i were in california
2007-2008 what happened to riverside
county
riverside county became poland after
world war ii but do you know what
happened
it was horrifying it's 60 percent of the
homes right
we're done because they're all over
leveraged they're talking about what
happened dude every single property
value dropped 60 percent
oh even phoenix those two were very
close pat tell them about the brand new
neighborhoods that were deserted the
lawns were dead
because people have been evicted these
are 200 250 000 houses they were sold to
people that should have been renting at
a more sensible thing and these were all
repossessed so now the bank owns this
neighborhood that looks like poland
after world war ii complete desolation
no grass of scary territory look like
who's the fault on that the banks the
people standards the real standards i
don't know let's talk about it everybody
was involved california
allowed the
financing regulations neenah and other
things to go on in its state
states like texas did not what did
california end up with that and where
were the vastness no income no assets
that's nina that's right where were the
vast majority of subprime lenders based
country-wide new century tony right
anthony anthony what was his name
anthony mazzillo and dietech scared me
because he was a well-spoken guy
people around here love scary orange
remember
zytec the great big billboards
you know
0.001 century was another one exactly
yeah so but but here's the point during
that time while he's saying this and
they're talking about texas which the
point they made i'm talking to a realtor
in plano you know what the guy says he
says oh during 2007-2008 plano worse
area took 10 hit maybe 15 it we didn't
feel it so so that's that's the benefit
that's the question that's the benefit
of that now who implemented those rules
do no income no assets no no no no the
why plano did this fall down
every state
every state can make credit card and
credit and lending laws okay texas said
twenty percent buffer
period twenty percent i'm going to drop
a big big housing bond here we go let's
go daniel there we go barry habib was in
the room he would he would
back slap me it would have hurt
as of yesterday's data or the girl that
was here with barrywood back from there
are there are more homes if you count
multi-unit and single-family under
construction since
1974.
new one
under construction under construction
right now since 1974 we haven't been
building this many houses and apartments
okay
one in four homes today according to
corelogic one in four homes today are
being bought all cash by investors
how is this going to end anybody heard
of zillow how is this going to end one
in four and that's why homestead is
being built are being purchased one in
four home sales in america today are
being purchased by investors investors
who are levered
they're buying all cash but the cash is
levered because they're taking advantage
of the zero interest rate policy at the
federal reserve you give me free money
and they're jacking up homes these
aren't individuals
who's trying to buy your first home even
if you've saved up the down payment
you're still going to lose because the
investor is coming in with all cash
but they're they're playing with
somebody else's money
and they're levered to the hilt and
they're like this is not the same thing
as the subprime crisis and i'm like yeah
you're right there's more debt involved
that's right there's no question there's
more debt involved but there's also
institutional money yeah hey pat what
percent and how how quickly do you think
they're going to hold on to these homes
if the peanut butter hits the fan
well we know what's going to happen the
investors okay real question here
instapoll
what
percent of the total housing
in america is owned by the top 10
percent
what percent of what percent of the
total housing in america is owned by the
i'm going to have to write this down
housing wealth no no no what percent of
all the homes correct of total housing
in america is owned by the top 10
percent i'm going to say 70 percent 45
okay and it's moving like seven percent
a year
so guess what in the last two years
yes okay so now the highest fico score
that's what mortgages highest fico
scores if she's right and the bubble
pops these people have got leverage
problems
if she's if the bubble doesn't pop she's
still right but if the bubble doesn't
pop
who's the new landlord's who's the surfs
and lords here
you're going to have 10 of america
owning over 50 of the housing in america
in 14 months because airbnb is hot vrbo
is high i'm not surprised about that
good way to make it and then guess what
top 10 percent or not
because what was the number on top ten
percent of stock market what was the top
ten percent in the stock market 89 it's
not on that but it's 89
okay i mean you know so i'm not i'm not
surprised by that matter of fact it's
lower than i thought it would be i
thought it'd be around six this takes us
back to why there will be bad policies
in the future because if something goes
wrong with this which it will when you
have wealth inequality that is that you
haven't seen wealth inequality like this
since prior to the fall of the roman
empire
when you have wealth inequality like
this even republicans will vote policies
in that you would consider to be
socialist you're saying what more
stimulus no 1978 jimmy carter wage and
price controls no
price controls i think i i think biden
is this close to gasoline price controls
i really do so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]